bonjour à tous aujourd'hui va parler de
google qui devrait arriver dans
l'univers du jeu vidéo très bientôt
plus précisément dans le cloud gaming
avec un projet qui s'appelle getty et ça
vous allez voir s'écouler on n'a pas
tout de suite
alors google tout le monde connaît la
marche in google google maintenant qui
est régie par f
alphabet qui roulait à grande maison des
reins qui gère google et tous les
services et une fois n'est pas coutume
google va se diversifier et cette fois
ci en arrivant dans le jeu vidéo
ils ont fait venir n'y a pas très
longtemps un spécialiste du jeu vidéo
qui a d'abord officié chez sony puis
ensuite chez microsoft et qui arrive en
tant que vice-président d'un service
donc pour l'instant on ne sait pas trop
ce qu'il est il ya un côté un peu secret
mais ce qui est très clair à ce qui se
profile c'est qu'effectivement google
est en train de se développer au niveau
du jeu vidéo
ce spécialiste s'appelle phil harrison
et phil harrison c'est quand même la
personne qui a fait repasser google du
géant qu'on connaît du web et qui va
ouvrir la brèche pour le jeu vidéo dans
le projet yéti qu'est ce que c'est le
projet yéti c'est tout simplement du
cross gaming le cloud gaming si vous
n'êtes pas forcément un grand amateur ou
un grand champion de jeux vidéo en ligne
vous connaissez pas forcément mais le
cloud gaming c'est vraiment la faune
dans ce qui est en train de se
développer
j'imagine qu'on est à votre écran vous
êtes très nombreux à connaître le cloud
gaming et pour cause parce que le cloud
gaming s'est jamais plus que du jeu
vidéo en ligne du jeu vidéo en streaming
imaginez un et flix un youtube en ligne
sur youtube donc imaginer youtube vous
avez toutes vos vidéos vous cliquez sur
de votre vidéo vous la regardez en
fonction de votre bande passante et bien
la vidéo va d'être d'une meilleure
qualité ou d'une moins bonne qualité
ça sera exactement la même chose pour
votre jeu vidéo c'est à dire que en
réalité vous allez choisir un jeu vous
allez jouer sur n'importe quel device au
total donc l'organique c'est un peu ça
l'idée n'importe quel device une
tablette un smartphone ordinateur une
console et que sais-je encore vous jouez
et si vous avez un peu moins de bande
passante 3g dès la qualité du jeu vidéo
va baisser
ça va pas les lags et par contre si vous
êtes sur la fibre avec une collection
qui dépote les quatre jeunes qui déchire
à ce moment là vous allez avoir un jeu
extrêmement agréable à regarder au
niveau graphique
parce que la résolution va augmenter ce
un peu ça l'idée du cloud gaming vous
avez un device du hardware vous avez un
ordinateur vous avez une smartphone une
console quelque chose comme ça et vous
jouez avec des jeux qui sont directement
en ligne
alors il ya plein de swat et de sociétés
qui se positionne dessus il ya déjà sony
avec son parti de son catalogue
vous pouvez jouer en club gaming qui à
microsoft qui va arriver dessus apple a
priori ainsi ci passerait dessus
pourraient d'ailleurs une boîte
française
déjà parlé il ya quelques temps
s'appelle black note qu'une boîte
rennaise qui est à rennes et à paris une
boîte que j'ai rencontré déjà qui est
top qui fait du cloud gaming
à l'époque où j'ai rencontré il ya un
tout petit peu moins d'un an il était
encore en version bêta là ça y est le
saint lys et en ligne d'ailleurs vous
invite à y faire un tour parce que
vraiment c'est un truc qui est top
et justement google devrait se
positionner sur ce genre de produit
alors qu'est ce que devrait faire google
on a parlé de cloud gaming google à base
de smartphones à base de tablettes abbas
d'ordinateur ça pourrait être le cas
mais le deuxième point qui en tout cas
pareil avec le plus probable c'est
vraiment l'arrivée du cloud gaming via
une console et une manette dédié google
c'est une info qui nous vient du site i
nformations qui nous dit effectivement
que google vraiment bosse sérieusement
sur ce projet parce qu'il est super
intéressant alors l'idée l'idée de base
c'est vous acheter une console une
console google un hardware
en gros vous allez avoir une espèce de
deux disques durs en ssd vous allez vous
connecter à internet directement dessus
donc il vous faut forcément une
connexion internet et vous allez pouvoir
jouer à l'ensemble du catalogue contre
un abonnement mensuel
alors c'est quoi l'intérêt pour
consommateurs parce que aujourd'hui on
va très bien comment marche le jeu vidéo
à l'état actuel en 2018 tout de suite
comment ça se positionne vous acheter
une console vous achetez des jeux vous
mettez dedans vous jouer quand vous en
avez marre vous avez fini vous avez
gagné vous vous calmez personnes chose
vous achetez un autre jeu neuf ou
d'occasion
voilà comment ça se passe l'idée du club
des mille c'est vraiment autre chose
d'autant plus quand on voit qu'il ya une
multiplicité des offres qui va arriver
vous devez donc avoir une augmentation
de la concurrence et pour le
consommateur ça se lettres mails des
prix ou du moins tout cas une offre
vraiment diversifié avec des licences
fortes avec plein de super cool dans
plein d'univers intéressant donc ça en
tout cas ça passe vraiment super cool
parce que on imagine très bien que des
jeux qu'on va retrouver chez black note
chez sony chez google chez microsoft on
vend des licences croisées meilleur
aussi des jeux des exclusivités compte
trois partout donc on va prendre un
abonnement d'un côté ou de l'autre en
fonction des jeux parce qu'on fait déjà
aujourd'hui sur des consoles en ckd
grands titres qui sortent sur plusieurs
consoles est et des exclus sur certains
produits notamment si je pense à
nintendo par exemple on a dit zelda
zelda nintendo les mario et compagnie
donc on devrait retrouver des
exclusivités forte chez certains
fabricants donc dans les plus je compte
forcément un grand catalogue une grande
diversité de jeu contre un abonnement
mensuel ce que permettrait de jouer à
plein de jeu contre un forfait alors
quel sera le tarif c'est un peu
compliqué à savoir je vous invite à
aller voir ce que fait bloc notes parce
que même si effectivement on est pas
tous sur des très grandes licences chez
black note ya une diversité de jeux qui
complètement dingue qui est vraiment
très intéressante et vous allez voir le
forfait de l'abonnement fondamentalement
est vraiment pas très cher maintenant on
n'est pas négatif parce que qui dit
claude deming dit quand même point
négatif puisque le club gaming c'est le
futur du jeu vidéo
le point qui est vraiment négatif c'est
d'une toux ceux qui n'ont pas de
connexion internet est bon dans le nom
lui voyez ce que je veux dire pas de
connexion internet pas de jeux en ligne
ou alors une connexion de mauvaise
qualité des jeux avec une collègue avec
une résolution en tout cas pas terrible
donc si vous jouez sur un smartphone
ça peut aller si vous jouez sur une télé
4k tout de suite ça va être beaucoup
plus compliqué donc on imagine à toutes
les zones qui ont une couverture qui
n'est pas terrible ça peut être
compliqué alors pour l'instant on n'est
pas encore la couverture du territoire
au niveau de la collection internet la
collectivité en tout cas se développe
énormément et de plus en plus la fibre
arrive de plus en plus en plus
d'endroits il ya quand même des zones je
pense notamment aux zones rurales qui
risquent de souffrir vraiment du club
des mille parce qu'ils ne pourront pas
forcément profiter de meilleure qualité
alors bon ça va on n'est pas non plus
dans un pays où la collection terre-net
n'est pas disponible partout on peut
quand même en avoir il ya différentes
solutions
donc effectivement il peut y avoir des
endroits qui seront difficiles notamment
pour ne la 4g voire même de la 3g mais
sur la plupart du territoire
on devrait pouvoir jouer en tout cas au
club games est d'ailleurs dit moi vous
est ce que vous êtes en france et est ce
que vous avez une bonne connexion
internet et est ce que le fait que le
jeu vidéo bascou d'ici quelques années
en cloud gaming a pas forcément sur
l'ensemble des offres mais sur une
partie de l'offre est ce que vous pensez
que ça pourrait être pénalisant pour
vous par kema tout ça aux commentaires
et autres points que je vois vraiment
bon en tout cas négatifs vraiment
problématique c'est que plus qu'il y
aura de plus en plus de clubs gaming y
aura
double il y aura désertification y aura
des boutiques qui devront fermer
mettre la clé sous la porte puisque il
n'y aura plus de jeux neufs à acheter et
plus de jeux d'occasion donc toutes les
boutiques qui vivent là dessus qu'ils
vendent des consoles quand ils devront
attendre des consoles parce que de toute
façon il va bien falloir avoir un
support physique notamment dans ce
projet ici google parce qu'a priori
durer effectivement une console physique
mais pour toutes les personnes qui vont
acheter des jeux qui vont chez des
micromania et compagnie essayer ça et
tous les autres et tous les indépendants
je pense en tous petits indépendants qui
font du jeu neuf du jeu d'occasion
et bien cela puisqu'il aura plus vieux
l'occasion plus de jeux neufs d'ici à
peut-être dix quinze ans peut-être même
avant et risquerait vraiment d'en
souffrir et un moment ou un autre de
mettre la clé sous la porte
à moins vraiment qu'on voit qu'une
explosion du rétro gaming avec foot ou
des personnes qui se mettent à jouer à
des vieilles consoles qui sauront les
xbox one x 1 à l'époque où des vieilles
nintendo nintendo ds ou compagnies dont
peut-être qu'il prend aussi un avis sur
le rétro gaming en tout cas sur le jeu
neuf et d'occasion très récent ça va
être compliqué parce que il devrait y
avoir plus grand-chose qui sortira de ce
côté là voilà un peu pour faire un point
on voit en tout cas que le monde du jeu
vidéo n'a pas fini de nous surprendre le
cloud gaming chose qui devient de plus
en plus fort qui va continuer à se
développer dit man vous ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous pensez que c'est une
belle avancée est ce que vous pensez que
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant ou est
ce que vous pensez c'est quelque chose
qui au final risque de nuire à pas mal
de monde risque de compliquer la vie
pour les personnes comme mauvaise
connexion internet et surtout de casser
un business pour tous des personnes qui
ont des boutiques qui vivent dessus
aujourd'hui marc qui m'a tout son
commentaire al de lire j'ai hâte de lire
vos commentaires vos avis vos questions
à tout ça tout ça tout ça tout ça je me
suis dit répondre dans la mesure du
possible je toujours un peu speed en ce
moment je sais c'est la course mais
rassurez-vous d'ici quelques temps ça va
aller beaucoup mieux merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je vous
invite comme d'habitude les cds jolie
pousse à vous abonner avec des
commentaires sur des bijoux de l'acdic
tous a à foison
merci à vous et à très bientôt je vous
embrasse soyez sages pour les soins de
vous ciao
[Musique]